sorry I'm late I went down a few
different alleys before I fell in this
one to run from some dogs their line
alleys in this neighborhood and feral
animals and nondescript white vans
actually it wasn't we have a rolling
calendar you have a fit is it good for
me I don't know Darnell salon they're
just listening off random date sometimes
get in here
thank you for being so flexible there's
all these drug dealers meeting and a lot
of coke and you know what it's like yeah
yeah yeah totally I I just I'm glad I'm
here with you for a one-week anniversary
you
am i training memory a stomach joke oh I
can fix this we need something to make
this intimate and romantic and not like
I completely forgot an anniversary no no
no this is this is actually a really
cozy surveillance man really yeah and
and watching you do the stakeout it's
actually nice use your words oh it's hot
watching you work
oh you're right if I don't get these bad
guys drugs are gonna flood the streets
and then millions of people want to
listen in oh my god
I get that all I'm saying is Ken Oshiro
mr. whooping his communications good
well centella needs to realize that Ken
Mashiro is running an entire crime
syndicate yeah but if Ken Oshiro would
just be open and honest about how many
kilos he can actually move I can't
believe your nonsense outside no of
course I'm not he cuts people's pinkies
up and eats them I kind of Cheryl
collects human teeth who's to say who
the better man is oh I could go get food
you remembered our anniversary you've
done enough I got us covered write down
everything they say
I'll be back in one second
I love rice with you I thought I was the
only one who ordered plain white Rex
drug-dealers good news it's because he
ulcers I'm just really picky oh my god
is this the drug dealers order
oh where the [ __ ] is my rice I drop my
gun in the alley on the way get the
tikka hey we're completely unprotected
what what do you know about Kevin sure
honestly that Ken Oshiro is not good
enough for Sam tella
no Santillan is completely happy with
Ken Oshiro he doesn't want to deal drugs
with anybody but Ken Oshiro
hey we got to cancel the drop tonight
and torture police vehicles no he only
wants to deal drugs
you this is the best anniversary ever
same time next week did you just say it
was the anniversary one week well I hope
you two are ready to spend eternity yeah
that's good look at our life because I
want you crazy kids to work it out